Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good morning!
Are you awake?
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us today for our 165th episode!
Let's get awake!
You know it's the start of a new week.
You better be late for it, Ruffians!
Still sleepy.
I guess it can't be helped.
Well, for those joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays, once a week.
So FUWAMOCO can get more balance in their lives, but also, PC-kun didn't agree to this last weekend,
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Ah!
Moco-chan!
Please say it after the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You better watch out Moco-chan, otherwise the Ruffians start saying it for you!
It's been a while!
BAU BAU!
You have to say the line, Moco-chan!
You gotta say it, otherwise the Ruffians are gonna say the line for you!
Say the line, Moco-chan!
Is that how it goes?
Yeah!
Say the thing!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, it's just about time to be a new month.
It's basically a new month.
There's been a bunch of things going on.
Let's take a look at them, Moco-chan.
But first, Ruffians, you need to tell us.
Our goal is to not go over an hour.
Please start yelling if we are getting close.
So, FUWAMOCO Morning!
Well, let's get to our first news of the day!
First thing is disappointing!
Moco-chan, we've had... The summer time is just about here!
There's a bunch of good things in the summer time!
July is officially summer!
It's the easiest way.
You know the boundary, yeah.
Well, the disappointing part is always that, so I guess that... That was sighted.
Another Pero sighting.
Is it something nasty?
Potentially.
We don't know yet.
Let's take a look what Pero was sighted.
Here we go.
3, 2, 1.
De-den!
D-DJ Pero!
What?
B-Bau?
He's DJing now!
I don't know, does anyone honestly want to go to a club where Pero's in charge of the music?
Nasty Beats?
Ruffians!
It's DJ Moco-chan!
Yeah, of course you wanna go, but... Not you, no.
Not you.
No.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
That's a good question.
Maybe... If you just feel the beat in his two bones inside.
It just goes right into his body, through the muscles, into the bones.
Maybe... Yeah, well... Yeah, I'm sure his mashups were extra nasty.
Yeah.
You know, maybe some Ruffians have fun.
Maybe.
I guess they make us happy, right, Moco-chan?
I mean, fun is always good.
Bye!
Nya?
DJ.
DJ no mina kawaii sou ne.
Nya?
Nya
We released a new cover song!
Yeah!
But not just any cover song!
A cover of the song Feeling Heart from Chihuahua!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO!
See, Mofans, you know FUWAMOCO, we actually sung Feeling Heart during our birthday lives in the old FUWAMOCO.
Ruffians, this time it's different.
You know FUWAMOCO always wanted to at least cover a feeling heart from ToHeart.
If you don't know what ToHeart is, ToHeart is a classic, legendary visual novel.
And also our favorite visual novel ToHeart is like...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Thank you Aqua for the support!
It's so good!
You know we got to play... We got to play the demo.
Not enough.
Not enough at all.
Sorry I fought with Mari-chan a bit.
I wanted to play as much as we could.
It was so much fun and we're so happy to finally be able to share something very special close to our hearts.
You know, true hearts together with you, Ruffians.
And especially our cover of Feeling Heart.
We love it!
If you could go take a listen, we put everything into it.
Another big
Thank you to Aqours for creating such a gorgeous video just like the original opening!
You really need to go check it out, Ruffians!
Don't miss it!
You know, Feeling Hearts has been a song that we've listened to that we've loved so so so so so many human dog years.
So we're really happy to be able to sing a song that's so close to our hearts for you, Ruffians!
I think our feelings are going across.
Maybe.
So we hope that you'll listen to it and that you'll check out QHeart, you know, it's a legend!
The legendary love comedy visual novel.
Our favorite heroine, our waifu, and the next FUWAMOCO.
But play her route at the end.
Yeah.
On.
QHeart again!
Yes!
QHeart!
It's very close to IHeart.
But, um... On the topic of QHeart!
You're like...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
20 lucky Ruffians will win.
I hope I'm part of that!
So please go repost, reshare, retweet, and also Ruffians, make sure you have a Japanese mailing address in the lucky case that you happen to be one of those 20 Ruffians.
I'm sure you know what's it, what's it, what's it.
What's it called?
What's it called, Moco-chan?
I'm so excited!
This is gonna be a challenge!
You see it?
It says FUWAMOCOXToHeart.
Do you see that?
This acrylic block did not attack my body, but I sure feel like I've been, like, hit in the heart!
Hit in the heart with an acrylic block!
Ow!
Yeah.
Can I just have all 20 of them?
I know, right?
I don't like all 20 of them, Ruffians, so... Dominoes.
You know what you're supposed to do now.
Dominoes!
Moco-chan!
I think we have to treasure them a little bit more than that.
It'll be cute dominoes.
BAU BAU!
And thank you for your cooperation!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Hi.
FUWAMOCO just having big big dreams come true.
Dreams that we never thought could come true.
That's all.
Casual.
Normal stuff.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Space on the field always limited.
First come, first served.
That makes sense, you can't fit everyone.
But you know you can bring your penlights and get ready to dance because there's a special dance party!
Yes, the dance party!
They're letting you know the set list.
So you better get really ready to- Grapple partner?
Grapple partner!
How you doin'?
Make sure you get all prepared.
You can practice.
Maybe meet up with some Ruffians beforehand.
Not this!
But that's not it!
Cosplay is also allowed you know!
There are some small rules.
In the small print there.
But it is allowed!
So you know I'm sure your FUWAMOCO happy.
Who do you like to cosplay as?
I think you have the perfect costume you know.
Oh maybe.
You could cosplay as FUWAMOCO!
Hi.
No!
I could cosplay as you, Moco-chan!
I guess that would work, right?
And then no one would know.
Right?
But also, also, also!
We have...
YAGOO-san's gonna be doing the first page!
Yes!
In the flesh!
Moco-chan, do you think you can throw better than YAGOO-san?
I really think I can.
Well, maybe you can go Ruffians and see just how well YAGOO-san does.
Moco-chan, you know you're up next time.
I know.
I think I can do better.
He might do really, really well, but I still... I think I can do better!
We'll see.
These are demon dog arms, okay?
Yeah!
That's how you do it, right?
Also!
There's gonna be exclusive merch, of course!
But also food and beverages!
They're just so cute!
The popcorn bucket!
Right!
That would be perfect for watch-alongs, right?
You can bring it home and you can put more popcorn in it!
Make sure you maybe clean it.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
And!
There's also gonna be mascots!
Yeah, it is!
Dogs!
Subaru dogs!
Indeed, they're gonna be there too!
And you can get some photos with them!
Subaru-senpai and Oni-senpai's mascot characters!
It's so cute!
Pero's gonna be there!
I don't know, Ruffians, you're gonna have to let us know!
But you know it's happening so soon, July 5th!
Yeah!
And!
Tickets!
There's tickets available!
You can go to the dodgies.com slash hololive.
I thought, you know, maybe they were sold out, but... Why?
It sounds so exciting.
There's... It's a big stadium, you know?
It's a big stadium.
There are still tickets!
You can click the buy now at the holo, and then enter the offer code.
See?
I thought all tickets were sold out.
They are not!
There's still tickets!
You know, maybe, but I don't really know baseball.
Then it's perfect, you know?
I think there's seats away from the people that are really interested in baseball.
I think this is the most popular seats.
I thought the other seats that were left were really good.
Oh, that looks like a really good seat.
But, maybe, maybe not.
It's kind of far from how the baseball happens to be.
I forgot about that part.
So, definitely, if you're in the area, do not miss this night to remember, okay?
I'm so excited.
I wanna go!
Oh, there's roll-in section seats.
I didn't know there were such things.
Those are the seats you want then.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Enjoy your baseball!
BAU BAU!
And what do they say when they do the good thing in baseball?
Strike!
Get ball!
Is that how it goes?
Play ball!
Yes, play ball!
That's what I was thinking.
BAU BAU!
And also!
Well, you know, lots of things happen in LA.
It's serious, right?
There's going to be a big Anime Expo happening!
And there's going to be the AXSCRIPT!
AXSCRIPT's going to be making an appearance there!
There's the Shibuya Style Design Coco and Anime Pop-Up!
And it's going from Shibuya all the way to LA!
You can see it at AX Anime Expo July 3rd to 6th!
There won't be the life-size...
FUWAMOCO deshita.
No, that makes sense.
But there will be the 1-7-I script FUWAMOCO figures on display!
So you can see them in person, how beautiful they are!
As well as exclusive merch too!
Up until now you had to go all the way to Shibuya in Japan to get your paws on them.
But now it's going to LA!
So hopefully it's cool soon.
Right, and we look so cool in our zero gravity battle outfits!
So we hope that you'll get your paws on them and maybe take a few photos of the 1-7 FUWAMOCO figures too!
The 1-1 scale statues got taken to our doghouse.
That would be nice.
They're still in Shibuya!
Shibuya style!
But yeah, unfortunately we're not making their way there.
You can't see them in Shibuya if you're in Shibuya.
BAU BAU!
Press Icomo if you'd like to enter the Expo!
Thank you!
Ruffians!
Even more exciting news really soon!
A very special senpai of ours is having her birthday!
ASCII-senpai is having a birthday live at FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be there!
Yes!
Oh my mama!
It's gonna be happening July 1st at 8!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Amazing, beautiful singing, but she has a very interesting song choice for a karaoke stream.
The way you said it makes it sound negative.
No!
You know, it's like, oh, this song!
Yeah!
You know, like, oh, I'm so surprised.
Yeah, we were talking to AZKi-senpai about, you know, karaoke songs too, right?
Right!
Like, there's been so many good karaoke songs!
That's all AZKi-senpai.
But you know, I wonder what kind of song we might be singing all together.
It's because of AZKi-senpai and FUWAMOCO, just so you know.
Yeah.
Happy birthday!
It's still a little bit early, but happy birthday AZKi-senpai!
It's still a little bit birthday, but happy early.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And continuing on all the exciting things, there was some big, big news for FUWAMOCO!
Oh, and more big news.
It was just announced that FUWAMOCO were making our debut as writers.
Because FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be having a column in the Legendary Gaming Magazine Weekly Family 2!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
We're so excited!
It's a huge honor!
Right?
Amazing!
And Koyori-senpai, she's gonna be having her own column too!
So FUWAMOCO code and Koyori-senpai's column in the following weeks after us.
But you know, FUWAMOCO, what are you writing about in a gaming magazine?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
We hope you can get your paws on it Ruffians!
But there will, I think there should also be digital versions that you can get online.
We don't know, but we're thinking.
Yeah, so you know if maybe going to your local konbini to get your paws on it is a little bit tricky.
Understandable.
I'd really be happy if you could check out the two.
You can buy it digitally!
Yes!
Okay!
Yeah!
Is there an English version?
BAU BAU.
I'm sure there are things that can help you.
BAU BAU!
We're really excited!
We'll do our bestest!
Ride a demon dog, FUWAMOCO-chan!
BAU BAU!
Excited!
Today is not just a lot of excitement going on, but it's also a special day!
A special day!
We have something to celebrate!
Celebration!
A pair of Ruffians!
They're actually getting married!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Wedding.
Happy year!
We're really happy for you!
Congratulations!
Soon to be happy-pumpy!
BAU BAU!
Wait, I just realized!
What?
BAU BAU!
Wow!
A lot's going on!
FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be making a big appearance at Cho-Cho-Cho-Cho Game Race 2 at Saitama Super Arena!
Game Race is having a big event happening on July 5th and 6th, so FUWAMOCO, we've been invited as guests for the 6th.
The 66th day of the event!
In person!
With a bunch of Ruffians!
Lots of gamers fans!
Lots of hearts!
Super Arena.
Can I say Choco-chan?
Choco-chan!
We'll be there together with Mikocchi-senpai and Subaru-senpai!
Fuwamico!
FUWAMOCO!
We'll definitely be getting into some silly times, playing some games maybe here and there.
Chiyoi!
Gamers!
Let's go!
BAU BAU!
We're so excited!
We're really excited to be able to see some Ruffians who are going to be coming to cheer us on there.
And you know, everybody there for gamers too!
And you know, even if you can't go, there are streaming tickets!
Yes!
They're available on Abema Live, so I really hope that you can join us there too, Ruffians!
And I'm sure most of you know this if you're curious about what happened at last Chou Gamers, there's also an archive of that as well on Abema Live!
I'm excited to go on the first Chou Gamers Live with all 4 gamers!
It's gonna be so much fun!
We're so, so excited!
I wanted to be guest too!
Will there be a preview?
I don't think so, but I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure there wasn't.
Don't be cool!
I'm pretty sure there wasn't last time, right?
Oh, I'm not sure.
I don't think so.
But you never know!
Yeah.
Please check it out!
I'll be online!
Not YouTube.
No.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I don't know what to call this.
Let's have an update.
Well, I guess it's happy.
Ruffians, you know our friend, right?
The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended up... The one we ended
We got a new family member!
Yay!
Someone to keep the friend a little bit company.
I feel mixed on this Moco-chan.
I feel mixed too.
So, today, you know, when we were going to the studio, we had a big day of recording.
But when we were walking there, we noticed something.
It's lying on the ground.
There was a big, beautiful butterfly!
One of the biggest we've ever seen!
And it wasn't moving, but you know, it was really hot!
So we thought, maybe I'll maybe just collapse something.
You know, it's so hot out.
Yeah, maybe I just need some sugar.
So we picked it up and we...
Took it over with us to the studio and then Morning-chan was like, I'm FUWAMOCO!
And we're like... Morning-chan!
What should we do?
The butterfly's passed out!
And Morning-chan was like... Huh?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
So we did what you would normally do.
Took a little plastic baggie.
And we took it home!
I can go in now!
I can keep our other friend, our cicada friend company until doing this and finally take ownership.
BABOO YOU'RE SUCH A BIG BEAUTIFUL BUTTERFLY!
Should we give her the name Moco-chan?
What should we name her?
Well Abyss, what should we name her?
Cuz we can't just say a friend.
Yeah.
No, we have two friends.
It's confusing.
It looks exactly like this.
Yeah.
Cho-cho.
Cho-cho?
We're calling it Cho-cho.
Cho-cho.
FUWAMOCO and CHO-CHO!
Put CHO-CHO like CHO-CHO-CHO gamers.
CHO-CHO.
Oh, like super super!
Super super!
CHO-CHO!
CHO-CHO-CHO ii kanji.
Yes, like that!
Stop doing that.
But you know, it's beautiful.
Yes!
It's super nice.
A little bit of complicated feelings.
My new family member!
BAU BAU!
Where is it?
It's on the... in the kitchen.
The plastic bag has a hole in it, but it's okay.
BAU BAU!
Make sure, Ruffians, make sure that the heat doesn't get to you, okay?
Don't end up like Jojo, okay?
How are you feeling, though?
The heat's not getting to you yet, is it?
Hopefully not.
It's been hot, it's been hot!
I'm staying hydrated!
You're not gonna die!
No.
You might just fall over.
Do you have anything that could help remedy those kind of... You know, the...
FUWAMOCO Feelings.
FUWAMOCO Worries.
FUWAMOCO Worries?
FUWAMOCO Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Huh?
FUWAMOCO I don't think so.
FUWAMOCO Don't think so?
FUWAMOCO Maybe you could try.
FUWAMOCO Huh?
FUWAMOCO A talk of sorts?
FUWAMOCO You would like a talk of sorts?
FUWAMOCO A little bit of a... FUWAMOCO A sort?
FUWAMOCO Like how I'm doing right now?
FUWAMOCO A pup talk.
FUWAMOCO Wow!
If you say so I guess.
Ruffians!
It's been a while, but it's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
It's the end of the month and guess what?
You did it!
You made it!
You got through it all!
You know, I'm sure there is busy times and rough days where you thought to yourself, How am I gonna make it through today?
But, you know what?
You did it!
And you'll continue to do it!
You know?
So make sure to celebrate those times when you overcome something big that was weighing on you, okay?
You have the strength to make it past anything that stands in your way, so believe in yourself!
Or else.
Okay?
There are lots of fun things coming up in summer, so let's get ready to rock July!
Ganbatte de!
Mawai!
Oppa!
Thank you, Moco-chan!
Or else, yes.
Or else, okay.
Let's rock!
Rock July!
BAU BAU!
I think it's time.
Time for FUWAMOCOchat.
The Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Den!
FUWAMOCO!
Oreo's already a menace and he will destroy toys if he's having fun.
I get that.
We all feel like that, right?
Does it count as a menace?
Some would call that a menace.
That's normal.
Moco-chan, how does Oreo BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
You know, we know that he'll bring you so many smiles in the future!
Even more than he already has.
Right!
BAU BAU!
BAU B
Look at that!
Beautiful!
It looks like it could be like a postcard.
It'll be really nice.
I'd really love to have photos like this, like a bunch of postcards for Ruffians.
Yeah!
That could be fun!
We could make it into a postcard and then use it as fan mail!
Yeah!
You could send it to us!
And then we could make a good special with it like a scrapbook or a collage catalogue.
Scrapbook.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
This looks like such a nice motorbike ride.
In the morning too.
Hopefully it wasn't too hot then.
It's a copa hot.
Copa?
I thought that was your bike's name.
Hopefully it doesn't get too hot, but morning sounds like a good time for a bike ride.
Make sure you don't forget sunscreen or hydration though.
I think you need more than just sunscreen.
Lots of sun hat stuff.
Can you wear a hat on a motorcycle?
Helmet.
Wear the helmet.
It'll protect your head more than your sunscreen.
BAU BAU!
Helmet, helmet.
You're a Ruffian, you know.
Obviously you can tell FUWAMOCO we don't really go on motorbikes or bikes.
Morning.
Next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Here's my question.
When you visit a new place, do you immediately take out your phone to snap photos, or do you prefer soaking it in with your own eyes?
I'm the latter.
I feel like I remember the experience better that way.
Thank you for your answer!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO, you know we went to Taiwan to visit Sushiro Taiwan Store's YouTube videos.
And we did take a lot of photos on our trip.
But that's because we want to share it together with you Ruffians.
Usually we don't take a lot of photos.
I like to take them with my eyes.
But I feel like if we do take photos, it's probably not all the normal stuff.
I think we're also part of the team that likes to just enjoy the experience.
You know, if it's a really special memory, then you'll remember it so vividly.
But I do like to take a photo!
Just for memory's sake.
But usually we forget.
One photo a day would be nice, you know?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for all your submissions!
Remember, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning is a show that we make together with you, okay?
So, we're always looking for your doggy of the days.
Your questions!
You can ask us lots of questions.
We are looking!
Pero Sightings!
Maybe you'll see Pero at the Dodgers game.
Or Saitama Super Arena!
Please share with us the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
And we have a stream coming up!
Yeah, our next stream!
De-den!
Our next Advent collab, we're gonna be playing V4!
And this time, you know, it's on Wednesday at 6pm PDT.
Thumbnail TBD.
Thumbnail TBD!
But, you know, there's been a big update, and even better than a big update, Nerissa's finally gonna be there!
We can all play, all five of us!
Yes, updated with Nerissa!
Oh, this old thumbnail, yes.
We're really looking forward to it!
It'll be on Wednesday at 6pm PT, so we hope that you'll join us there, Ruffians!
And in the meantime, we'll do our best, so... BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU BUTTERFLY!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Mococo Abyssgard!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!